in a gallery in west palm beach florida
hangs an american picture story shot
by a scotsman
and that's the money shot yeah harry
benson's portfolio
spans more than 50 years and every u.s
president since eisenhower
the secret to this famous image of the
reagans was the soundtrack music
supplied by the photographer nancy with
the laughing
face no great prayer to
news and she said oh my gosh
my favorite song in the clinton white
house
there was love and a hot temper i think
the woman in love
decent guy got a terrible tamper
never showed it with me but he does
the one i phoned called was obama
it wasn't there was no every one of them
wanted to know a little bit about you
you're not just some button pusher
he was cold of all the white house
residents captured by harry benson
donald trump isn't among them not as
president
i told them i i want i would like to go
to the white house and photograph you at
the white house because i haven't seen
any pictures of
you there and he said no
that's fine but it also leads me up to
to use other pictures that i know he
doesn't like
him grabbing money holding a million
dollars when he opened his casino up
i know he hates it it shows greed
and he should have said yes
for no other reason
he's known me for 40 years and i've done
i gave him a lot of cupboards
he won't allow me that he says no to me
coming up and taking
a picture in the
white house
the story of an image problem in the
white house
not for the first time james matthews
sky news
in west palm beach florida